REGULATION LOSS I
SOROKIN.
COACH.
>> Brendan: AND GRUDEN IS BACK
FOR THE
HE'S A AN OPPORTUNITY AS
TATAR DRIVING TO THE NET AND
GOODBAN.
MOVES IT NOW.
DAWSON MERCER TO THE BOARDS.
MERCER TO THE BETWEEN THE DEVIL
ISLANDERS.
GILES IS ABLE TO
>> Brendan: MAYBE.
HAD A 28-SECOND SHIFT EARLIER.
THIS ISHLSTROM.
CROSSING INTO THE ISLSLCE THAT
BLUE LINE, GREAT TRANSITION
GAME HOW DEEP SOROKIN IS.
ISLANDERS BUT IT'S A 1-0 DEVILS.
>> Brendan: SHARANGOVICH COMIN
PENALTY.
THAT WILL COST THE ISLAUVILLIER
PUTS IT DOWN AND SHOOTS IT.
THEY SCORE!
BAILEYISH CAN HANDLEO THE NEUTR.
SAID THEY MIGHT
BARZ AL
GOAL.
PARISE IN FRONT AGAIN AND I
DON'T KNOW IF HE GOT THAT OR
NOT.
IT DOESN'T AND ADAM PELECH
GETS THE GOAL HERE IN.
AND IT DOWN.NEAR LIVELY TURNED
PARISE HAS BEEN A ZONE.
SHARANSOROKIN.
>> Butch: STRONG ALONG THE
BOARDS.
LOST THENG TO EVEN GOALIE HAD T
COME UP WITH A BIG, BIG SAVE.
LOOK AT THE MOVE BY HUGHES.
KEEPS THE FEET
IT A
IT'S A L.
HISCHIER.
FOR SMITH.
THEY SCORE!
NATE, ALWAYS HARD.SEY.
DEVILS 4-2 IN THEIR LAST SIX IS.
>> Brendan: BAILEY.
BAILLY RETURNS THE PASS AND
THERE IT IS, A SKATES OF SMITH.
1:08 TO